our story on Donald Trump's reading
level has gone viral in France multiple
websites news magazines and TV shows
using our clips to talk about the story
in France there's a show called set a
vous just the letter C right apparently
quite popular
check out my mug on the screen behind
them in the clip we're about to play for
you something about this is funny when
they start talking about the clip they
put a picture of me up on the screen
right I'm just grinning and it's
completely just a sort of out of place
in the story that they're talking about
but it's hilarious here's a little bit
if you don't understand French the only
thing you might pick up on is when they
say my name in French but it's very
funny check it out Celia who's my AV
demo in Syria in Safari Mostafa poetry
tell Paul Mitchell kafebludd early radio
compound effect model low tech zone
Arista Mira que tipo de gestion
s'appelle David pac-man Alexa many ideas
Asian important point if I finally given
more sample model EFS chimera and DoCoMo
idea so kilo COBOL Donald Trump can
comfortably read the written English
language I mean like English written on
pages I genuinely think after reviewing
a bunch of videos and comments and
evidence yesterday that Donald Trump may
barely be able to read would you be able
to read this section and tell us what
your understanding of it is I mean you
want me to read it ah long it is long
very long I know I have my glasses
- all right let me try largest island I
have to place on the record a hearty
objection
he'll evoke little net trapped
indigenous jelly donut country Gila net
no equity dose of caramel are washable
one Sukhois - salamati lady she need a
Realtor buyer of the week she's cupid
escucha if you're only listening to that
another really great moment is when
they're playing the clip of me talking
about it they go to a reaction shot of
the panel that's discussing this and
they seem hugely entertained by the
entire thing and they're also just
completely confused because I mean I'm
sure they probably do understand English
or can read the subtitles there but with
the content of what's going on the
American president can't read I mean
that's a flexing absolutely also on a
program called 20 minutes 20 minutes dot
SR is the website the story also coming
up in France his advisors have now also
said Trump avoids reading any report or
briefing that he finds to be too lengthy
and he will often just glance at the
first page without even making it
evident whether he understands one page
I recently saw this interview with
Saturday Night Live's Pete Davidson so
during like the table read he like I'm
not going to say this so they would say
it the way I would say his lawyer
clearly doesn't want Trump to do any
reading out were out loud would you be
able to read this section and tell us
what your understanding of it is
objection yeah also in a weekly French
news magazine based in the lovely second
to run this Mont of Paris called love
I'll just put up a screenshot of this
article for you and also a written piece
about it I like it I like the David
Pakman show with French subtitles it
really gives it a whole new vibe doesn't
it I always love it when the show gets
international notoriety because I'm
there on the outside and can kind of
laugh at the things going on in our
country we have to avoid crying they
laugh because they're laughing yeah
they're more removed from it I mean
we're more in a dangerous situation oh
it says yeah no doubt about it so yes
the can trump read story all over french
me
and great great stuff